hey all you cool cats and kittens carol
i am so excited to meet you we are so
excited to watch you
how did you end up on this season of
dancing with the stars and why was it
the perfect
next move for you the perfect next move
we had over 190 media outlets reached
out to us after tiger king and we turned
all of them down but my daughter saw the
list and she said you got to do
jimmy fallon and you've got to do
dancing with the stars jimmy fallon
turned out to be a prank
dancing with the stars turned out to be
the real thing and so
we accepted that challenge even though
it's
just totally outside of my comfort zone
how are rehearsals going i have a dream
of seeing you incorporate your bicycle
and your flower crown a little bit is
that happening
so far no bicycle or flower crown has
been presented to me but i'd be
happy to do that the rehearsals have
been fabulous the pros
are amazing they can teach anybody to
dance if they can teach me to dance
well we can't wait i mean you look great
by the way you're are you you're looking
like a dancer are you getting fit doing
all this
it is a lot of work and i i don't have a
set of scales but i think it's already
starting to help
well dancing with the stars is about
dancing but it's also about
sharing your journey who you are fans
saw a certain side of you on tiger king
are you going to use dancing with the
stars to
show them you know the you that you want
to portray will you make some reveals or
or write what you might see as some
wrongs that might be out there
there's plenty of wrongs but this isn't
about me this is about the cats and they
were the real losers in tiger king
it was about this much attention paid to
what those cats go through
so i am really hoping that dancing with
the stars will
keep those cats first and foremost in
the front of the viewers
so that they are constantly thinking
about those cats being in cages and
being exploited
so that we can change that and end the
private possession
and the customer well i see you wearing
your cat print right now always
but dancing with the stars is also the
chance for you to it's about your
journey you know and i wonder
are you excited to get to show who you
are
on your terms you know with saying what
you want to say and doing what you want
to do instead of it maybe being in the
editing hands of someone who you
you might not not have known what they
were going to do with it
well it always falls to the editor but
in my case i have always been
strictly focused on protecting big cats
and saving them in the wild
the editors of tiger king chose not to
focus on that part of what i do
i'm really hoping the editors at dancing
with the stars too
will we see you make any big reveals on
the show this season
i don't know what there is to reveal
other than the fact that
there is work that we can do to save
these cats and to protect them in the
wild before they completely go extinct
so if america doesn't know how close we
are to losing the majestic tiger then
that will be the big reveal
could we see you dance to eye of the
tiger that feels right for that first
dance
just a minute ago i got approval to be
able to tell you
the first person to get to hear we are
opening my
act with eye of the tiger
[Music]
it was carol that is amazing
congratulations that's so awesome any
other critical
cat focused songs that you had on your
list i have a bunch of other cat themed
songs on there but i don't know
yet what will be incorporated will we
see you wearing tiger print or cat print
in this first dance
the people in wardrobe asked me you know
what they could do
and i told them just absolutely go wild
so i think
you are gonna be as surprised as i am i
gotta ask you
would you ever and i don't know if
they've asked you but would you
dance to one of joe exotic songs just to
have a little fun
there was nothing fun about the things
that he said about me
okay well like i said here's the thing
carol dancing with the stars is your
moment
you can do what you want to do so i'm
like carol own this take back that
narrative you know
thank you we have seen you absolutely
explode this year
a tiger king now you're on dancing with
the stars
and now you've got people playing you in
scripted projects kate mckinnon is gonna
play you how does it feel to be having
this moment like to have her
taking you on i'm really excited about
the idea that they could give
more time to some of the issues but
nobody has reached out to me from any of
these productions for me to know
whether or not they're just rehashing
more of the same
nonsense that was portrayed in tiger
king or if they're really doing any kind
of an in-depth
study i don't know how they could be if
they don't reach out to me to ask
that's fair well again dancing with the
stars carol this is your
your journey and we're all excited to
see it uh how have you felt about the
fan reactions to you being on this show
it's really been positive anything in
person has been absolutely positive
the only negative type of impact from
tiger king
from dancing with the stars has been
where people can hide behind
an alias phone number or a email address
so people in person have been wonderful
have you been getting
some of that hate messaging and and kind
of the trolls
after tiger king aired my phone went off
every two minutes around the clock
for three months and it was mostly
people screaming how much they hated me
for having tigers in cages because
they didn't understand from tiger king
that you can't just rescue a tiger and
turn it loose
it has to live in a cage and so they
didn't understand the whole
message of sanctuaries trying to end the
breeding so the tigers aren't in cages
so the good news is
most of the people out there are really
in our tribe they're on our side in this
they just didn't know it after watching
tiger king have you heard from any of
the tiger king cast about you being on
dancing with the stars
you know i i don't think i have about
dancing with the stars
are you preparing yourself that you
might have to fend off some of that
negative press and reaction from them as
this season goes on i think it'll be
dissipating because
the more people are learning about the
real issues because
thankfully it is in the public
discussion now and people are starting
to research it and they're finding out
that tigers are disappearing in the wild
and they're finding out that breeding
them
in cages is not saving them in a while
so as more and more of that information
gets out there there's less and less
negativity
well carol i'm excited to see you
potentially win this whole thing i think
you've got it
thank you